everyone knows that work is lame even if
you're an actor sometimes all the fame
and money that come with a big role
don't seem to be worth enduring a cruel
director or a miserable film set
we've already spotlighted a few times
where one scene nearly caused an actor
to walk away but it's apparently a lot
more common than you think we explored
some maddening moments that drove our
actors crazy in our earlier video scenes
that almost caused the actors to quit
well now we're back with more scenes
that almost pushed actors right over the
edge Daisy Ridley in Star Wars The Force
awakens starring in one of the most
anticipated movies of the century is an
opportunity most actors would kill for
but the pressure of filming 2015 star
wars the force awakens
nearly proved too much for Daisy Ridley
the British newcomer didn't have much
experience before JJ Abrams cast her as
Rey and screen ran reports that she
almost quit on the first day when he
told her that her performance during a
desert scene felt wooden that note along
with bearing the weight of the biggest
franchise in movie history almost
prompted ridley to get on a starship to
anywhere far far away Shelley Duvall in
the shining Shelley Duvall sent an
guinness world record for her portrayal
of Wendy in Stanley Kubrick's 1980
horror classic The Shining but it's not
a record anyone would want the
perfectionist Kubrick insisted on 127
takes of a scene where Duval's
hysterical character uses a bat to fend
off a deranged Jack Nicholson by the end
she was so exhausted and dehydrated from
crying that she nearly quit she didn't
but the stress of filming the scene was
bad enough that she reportedly began
losing her hair Zoe Saldana Pirates of
the Caribbean before she landed leading
roles in huge blockbusters like Avatar
and guardians of the galaxy Zoe Saldana
was just another struggling actress
getting by on bit parts she had a small
one as Anna Maria in 2003's Pirates of
the Caribbean the curse of the Black
Pearl and she said she was treated so
badly that she nearly quit telling The
Hollywood Reporter it was very elitist
people disrespected me because they look
at my number on a Call Sheet and they
think that I'm not important it was so
demoralizing Saldana said she even
considered quitting acting altogether
annamaria I suppose you didn't deserve
that one even not that one autism Mike
Myers in Wayne's World Mike Myers
created the character of Wayne Campbell
on Saturday Night Live and the
reoccurring sketch became so popular
that paramount wanted a Wayne's World
movie Myers heard the screenplay
and he was especially excited about the
scene where Wayne and the boys pack into
the mirth mobile and head bank to
Queen's Bohemian Rhapsody but the studio
wanted to replace the song with
something fresher and cheaper to license
Myers thought the Queen song was crucial
as he revealed on WTF with Marc Maron
and at one point I said to everybody
while I'm out I don't want to make this
movie stop Bohemian Rhapsody and they
were like who the [ __ ] are you yeah I
said I'm somebody that that wants to do
that movie that's the movie I want to do
both Myers and Bohemian Rhapsody stayed
gene Hackman and the French Connection
gene Hackman won an Oscar for his turn
as New York City police detective Jimmy
Popeye Doyle in 1971 s the French
Connection but it almost didn't happen a
notoriously difficult actor he often
clashed with director William Friedkin
especially after freecam revealed that
Paul Newman was his first choice for the
part things came to a head in the scene
where Hackman dressed in a Santa Claus
costume tackles a criminal on the street
freakin demanded 27 takes and Hackman
nearly quit fortunately he stayed and
even mentioned it in his speech at the
Academy Awards John Cena in 12 rounds
whew wrestling stars are bigger than
John Cena
so when WWE produced the direct-to-video
cop thriller 12 rounds in 2009 casting
him as the lead was a no brainer
although his day job is to battle
hulking beasts in the ring
Cena apparently isn't fearless one scene
called for his character to rappel down
a skyscraper and dangle midair from a
rope but Cena revealed later that his
severe fear of heights triggered intense
anxiety and he considered walking away
before he even got up there Mary
Elizabeth mastrantonio in the abyss the
dark claustrophobic sets and constantly
gushing water made for some difficult
days on the set of James Cameron's 1989
sci-fi flick the abyss but one day in
particular stands out for Mary Elizabeth
mastrantonio for a scene in which her
character is estranged husband
ministers her CPR Cameron asked co-star
Edie Harris to frantically slap
mastrantonio as she lay motionless on
the cold wet floor then the camera ran
out of film and enough was enough and
she heard that she's just like freaked
she just said hey man we are not animals
I don't know what you're doing here but
we are not animals after leaving the set
she eventually calmed down and returned
Carl Weathers in rocky for a big part of
the 4th rocky movie involves Rocky's
mentor Apollo Creed staging a comeback
played by former NFL linebacker Carl
Weathers Creed gets roughed up in the
ring pretty bad by communists pugilist
Ivan Drago played by Dolph Lundgren but
one of the boxing scenes got a little
too real when London threw weathers into
a corner causing weathers to break
character and throw a real punch
Lundgren responded in kind knocking
weathers out when he regained
consciousness he quit the movie and sent
production into limbo for four days
that's when Sylvester Stallone finally
convinced weathers to return Tippi
Hedren in the birds Alfred Hitchcock had
a reputation for being unkind to
actresses but if he hendren signed on to
1963 as the birds under the guarantee
that she'd only be attacked with
mechanical birds during the film's
climactic scene but Hitchcock is the
king of twists and he won ahead drinks
terror to feel real so he instructed
crew members to throw real live birds at
her this real-life game of Angry Birds
went on for five full days and Hedren
had a breakdown when it was over she
only finished the movie when a doctor
ordered Hitchcock to give her a week off
to recover thanks for watching subscribe
to our YouTube channel to watch more
videos like the one you just saw and
leave us a comment to let us know which
scene would have made you quit
[Music]